lynne margulis's theory that evolution
is a process involving interdep
interdependency rather than competition
amongst among organisms
differs dramatically from most
biologists
or no error
so this is a little interesting let's
just think about what what the sentence
is comparing they're comparing lynne
margulis's theory that evolution is a
process involving interdependency rather
than competition among organisms they're
saying that that theory differs
dramatically from most biologists
so this this sentence as it's
constructed right up right over here
it's comparing a theory
it's comparing lynn margulis's theory
it's comparing that to they're saying
the theory differs dramatically from
most biologists well this is weird
you're comparing a theory to people
you're comparing a theory to biologists
no what you really want to do is compare
the theory to the biologists theory to
the biologists ideas so if you wanted to
make this make sense you would say
differs dramatically from not most
biologists you would want to say most
most biologists
most
biologists and it's possessive most
biologists
theories
theories or ideas so you would cross
this out notice you're comparing lynne
margulis's theory to and you're saying
lynn margulis's theory differs
dramatically from
not most biologists but differs
dramatically from most biologists
theories you want to compare lynne
margulis's theory to the other biologist
theories you don't want to compare a
theory to the actual people that's just
you're comparing comparing we're you're
comparing well that doesn't make sense
you're comparing an idea to
actual physical living human beings
so definitely error in part d